beyonce knowles also known as queen bee
is one of the most successful artists
alive today
she was born in houston texas her mother
tina owned her own hair salon her father
was a salesman at xerox
beyonce's little sister solange would go
on to later become a famous singer in
her own right
you could say beyonce was discovered in
first grade her dance teacher encouraged
her to enroll in the school talent show
which she won
she enjoyed the limelight at just nine
years old bee joined an r b group girls
time and eventually made it to the
popular tv show star search her raw
talent was undeniable
b's father quit his job to focus on
making her and the rest of girls time
famous creating a superstar boot camp of
sorts
they would soon be rehearsing with a
media coach choreographer and voice
teacher who for a time lived in an
apartment over b's garage
as girls time continued to evolve they
played wherever they could church
services local fashion shows six flags
even grocery store openings
as they continued to develop the group
changed its name to destiny's child
in 1997 the group inked a deal with
columbia records and released its first
single killing time which was featured
on the men in black soundtrack
their self-titled debut album was
released in 1998 and just like the first
group members rotated in and out making
a splash on yet another movie soundtrack
[Music]
destiny's child now composed of beyonce
michelle williams and kelly rowland were
at the top of the charts
in 2003 beyonce released her first solo
album earning five grammy awards
she flourished as a solo artist and
continued to release albums
and at 2018's beachella i mean coachella
beyonce pretty much broke the internet
beyonce was the first black woman to
headline the music festival coachella
and her performance was the most
streamed coachella video on youtube ever
she released her concert documentary
homecoming which went on to win a grammy
for best music film and we can't forget
some of the other films she was in it's
me
foxy you're sophisticated look
you have to take your place as king it's
been five years since she's released a
solo album but she continues to rack up
awards using her voice to fight for
social justice and gender inequality
this summer she released a new swimwear
line that she collaborated on with
adidas
and of course she's one half of
hip-hop's billion dollar power couple
bay and jay as fans call them have three
children together and own homes in los
angeles and new york
beyonce is worth an estimated 440
million dollars and is number 73 on
forbes 2021 list of america's richest
self-made women
[Music]